Today for our experts in emotion interview.
We'll be speaking with Dr Judith Moscowitz on emotion and physical health.
Doctor Moscowitz is an associate professor in residence and the Department of
Medicine and the Osher Center for Integrative Medicine at the University of
California San Francisco.
She received her phd in social psychology from Dartmouth College and our mph in
epidemiology from UC Berkeley.
Her research is focused on coping and emotion in the context of chronic stress.
In particular,
she studies the impact of positive emotion on psychological and physical
adjustment to serious stress and illness using both quantitative and qualitative
methodologies.
She examines how caregivers and those with chronic illness appraise and cope
with the illness related stress and how those processes are related to
wellbeing.
Doctor Moscowitz is the Pi of an NIH funded randomized controlled trial of an
intervention designed to increase positive effect during a stressful health
related event such as testing positive for HIV.
She's modifying the positive effect intervention for high school and middle men,
middle school students,
people with type two diabetes,
women with stage four breast cancer and university employees and testing in
person and online approaches to delivering the intervention.
So I now turn to a very special experts in emotion interview together with Dr
Judith Moskowitz on emotion and physical health.
Welcome Judy.
Thanks for speaking today.
Thanks.
I'm sorry to be invited to be part of the series.
Hmm.
What I wanted to start out asking you about was a little about your journey into
the world of emotions.
So where did it first get started for you?
Well,
it started,
I think for like it is with a lot of people that started in graduate school.
Um,
I went in really interested in psychology and the effect of stress on health,
which is,
uh,
led me directly to the work of Lazarus and Folkman and looking at stress and
coping theory and emotion is an integral part of that theory.
Um,
and as I started doing some research in the area,
um,
uh,
the,
my interest is sort of differentiating between positive and negative emotion.
And the differential effects started to emerge.
So working with my advisor at Dartmouth j hall,
um,
he was also a really get into it getting into structural equation modeling at
the time.
So we started looking at the structure of coping and the structure of emotion
and started really looking at a positive emotions and negative emotion as
separate concepts at that point.
Um,
yeah,
so it's,
it's,
it's been,
you know,
a good 20 years.
Well,
I mean,
and over that 20 years you've done I think so many exciting things in this
realm.
So I still want to ask you to speak a little bit about them because I know a lot
of people listening to this conversation or really interested in thinking about
the fact that emotions can actually tangibly affect really important physical
health outcomes.
So I mean,
one area among many that you've done is,
um,
your work where you're really well known for this influential work on the
predictors and consequences of positive effect,
uh,
in the context of health related outcomes such as chronic stress.
And I wondered if you could say a little bit about what you see as the most
important discoveries here in your work?
Well,
I think the core discovery,
that positive emotion,
it does have a unique role in health and that,
um,
it,
it influences really important health outcomes like mortality.
Um,
that was really where I started with this work,
sort of,
um,
looking in other datasets earlier datasets that where the data had already been
collected and looking for this unique relationship.
And once we found the relationship between positive emotion and longer life,
um,
that opened up a whole world of possibilities for looking at,
well,
okay,
yeah,
it's great you live longer.
But what leads to that and sort of all the steps in between,
is it health behaviors?
Is it immune function?
Is it other biological mediators that we have yet to really understand?
Um,
so at that point I think things really opened up,
but the starting with,
you know,
positive emotion leads to longer life,
which is fascinating,
right?
Because most people might've thought positive emotions is just kind of this
epic,
phenomenal thing that happens,
but that you should actually really drives,
you know,
important health outcomes.
Huge.
Yeah.
It was really exciting.
It's the only time,
you know,
of the millions of analysis I've done where I had literally jumped out of my
chair and ran into someone else's office and said,
look,
it's really there.
It's really true.
So it's been really exciting and really launched a lot of,
um,
work that I'm,
you know,
our whole team is really passionate about.
Yes.
I wanted to ask you,
I mean,
have you found distinct kinds of predictors when you looked at varied
populations?
I know you've said it,
caregivers,
people newly diagnosed with HIV as well as those with pancreatic tumors.
Are you finding distinct effects in these groups or is there a common theme
across,
um,
we're not at a point with our intervention work where we're seeing a
differential effects based on the type of illness or the type of stress.
My Gut instinct is that the illness or the,
um,
the particular stressor that,
uh,
the samples dealing with is not going to be the key thing driving the outcome.
I actually think they're probably the,
the question of
when is positive emotion,
um,
a key predictor of health and for whom is it a key predictor?
I think it's going to come down more to personality variables.
Um,
and again,
it's too early in our data to to see that.
Um,
but that's,
that's my gut of where things are headed.
So interesting.
It seems like there's so many like exciting unknown's too on the horizon.
Yes.
Yeah,
a huge,
um,
huge new territory for research I think.
So I wanted to ask you then about this seminar work you've done examining these
positive effect related interventions aimed at helping reduce stress across a
variety of populations.
And I wondered if you could say in your opinion,
what you see as some of the most essential ingredients of these interventions
that's making them work and really amazing and maybe surprising ways.
Yeah,
I think,
um,
our basic idea is that,
so we,
we've developed this intervention that has eight or coping skills for increasing
positive emotions sort of on a daily basis.
Um,
even if you're experiencing stress,
we think that these skills can help you,
um,
increase your daily experience of positive emotion and help you cope with the
stress better no matter what the stress is.
Right?
So the idea is that we are giving people this toolbox,
this buffet,
the s a selection of skills to choose from.
Um,
the real trick is that you then have to practice the skills,
like make it a habit.
Um,
so where we're really headed with this is not so much that,
you know,
we think that mindfulness is the key thing or positive reappraisal is the key
thing or noticing positive events or gratitude.
We think all of these things can work.
Um,
if you make it a habit.
so where our work is really heading now is trying to figure out how to help
people engage in these skills and make them part of their daily lives and part
of how they think about the world.
And how they view the world.
Um,
so,
uh,
you know,
I think there's,
there's a lot of really good work being done out there that looks at,
um,
a lot of these skills sort of individually.
And I think that we're all really important and should definitely be pursued.
But for our main questions it's more about,
um,
we think there's enough evidence for each of these skills for it to be included
in the package.
But now we're moving forward and trying to figure out ways to deliver the
intervention and to make it appealing to people and make it and help people stay
motivated to engage with the skills.
Yeah.
So when I think about different kinds of individuals and gate,
uh,
engaging with these skills,
do you find that certain individuals are benefiting more from certain skills
than others or some individuals may not be benefiting from certain components?
I think there's,
there's definitely a lot of individual differences in how much people like the
skills and how much people practice the skills.
And again,
our work,
most of our studies are at a very early pilot phase where we're just trying to
deliver the skills and have them understand it and looking to see if people are
practicing.
We have one large trial going on now that'll be,
um,
probably about 160,
175 people newly diagnosed with HIV and half of them will be given the skills
and that once the data are in for that study,
we'll have more of a sense of really,
you know,
we'll be able to look at the data and see,
um,
are there,
what are the individual differences that drive who takes up which skills and
what works and for whom.
I can tell you anecdotally that there are some people who,
and it's surprising to me when we put together the eight skills,
there are some,
there's something for everyone.
I'll almost,
without exceptions did people can find one of those eight that really speaks to
them.
Um,
and at the same time there's usually one that they just can't stand or they say,
oh yeah,
I already do that and they have no interest in.
And really looking at it and trying to make it more of a habit.
So,
um,
I think mindfulness is probably the best example in terms of people love it.
Or then there's also people who just hate it.
They hate the breathing meditation and they hate the bell.
They need everything about it.
So,
um,
yeah,
it's been really fascinating to listen to and we get a lot of participant
feedback cause we're piloting so much of this.
Um,
but it's been really fascinating to hear people really radically different
responses to the individual skills.
Have you found any individuals respond in a way where they have skepticism about
how can I be building positivity in an authentic way that's not promoting this
kind of,
you know,
Pollyanna view of the world that,
everything is fantastic and great.
Okay.
Right.
And we are really careful to,
um,
not,
uh,
not be Pollyanna about this.
So we really,
and again,
coming from a background in stress and Cook Clean Research,
we're very aware that,
you know,
life is hard and really bad things happen and we aren't minimizing the real
negative consequences in the real stress that people experience.
So we're really careful to,
um,
honor the stress that they're undergoing and we're explicit about it.
So in our work with people with HIV,
we acknowledge that they are,
you know,
participating in this study because they've just been diagnosed with a really
serious illness and we do not,
um,
in any way encourage them to,
uh,
suppress the negative emotions or deny that their life is stressful or that what
they're going through a stressful.
Um,
instead we really point to the data and we say that,
you know,
we've,
we've done a number of studies now of people experiencing really serious stress
and what we see is that even though there is a lot of distress and there is
depression,
there is sadness and there's fear and anxiety.
There's also a positive emotion alongside that and that,
um,
people reported this to us.
We didn't go in looking for,
uh,
for report.
It's a positive emotion,
but this is what the participants were telling us.
So when we're trying to teach people the intervention,
even though they're going through a really significant stressful event,
we,
we give them the data and we say,
you know,
there it is possible to feel the positive alongside the negative.
So what we're trying to do is teach you skills for making more room for the
positive.
Hmm.
So almost finding that balance as opposed to just being completely skewed in one
way that's Pollyanna.
It's balancing the positive with the reality of the negative stress that they're
facing.
That's right.
Yeah.
I think,
you know,
in the field has sort of swung back and forth on this as well as,
it's um,
you know,
for a long time psychology was really focused on the negative and that's
important and it continues to be important and we need to figure out ways to
reduce,
um,
out of control,
negative emotions.
Sure.
And then we started discovering that positive emotions had these sort of unique
beneficial effects.
So then,
you know,
to some extent we swung maybe too far in the other direction.
We're like,
well,
let's just all look at positive emotion and see what we can do there.
But,
you know,
extreme positive isn't good either.
So.
Yeah,
exactly.
So it's the balance and finding the balance and helping people find that
balance.
So it makes me think about,
you know,
the volume that you and I have been co-editing.
Um,
the title,
the dark and light sides of positive emotion.
I'm with Oxford University press,
really thinking about these,
you know,
two facets of the ways in which positive emotions can have all these robust
benefits for us,
but when taken to an extreme or experience in the wrong context may actually be
maladaptive for us.
And I wonder,
you know,
from your perspective on you,
and I've had a lot of conversations about this,
you know,
in what way can positive emotions really have these two sides,
right?
I mean,
it's,
I think counterintuitive to a lot of people that really see positive emotions,
you know,
as a,
as a way through which you experience all these fantastic robust effects.
And how could there be a dark side?
Right,
right.
Yeah.
I mean there's,
again,
I'm,
I'm in our work,
we're really careful to acknowledge the dark side and acknowledged that this
isn't all about positive emotion and certainly clinically you can swing way too
far in the positive direction.
One of the,
the studies we're working on right now with,
uh,
Sherry Johnson at Berkeley is um,
modifying and tailoring our positive effect intervention for people with bipolar
disorder.
Because there's a real question for people who are at risk for mania.
Do you want to give them skills for experiencing lots of high activation,
positive emotion and a number of our skills?
Um,
things like,
um,
goal setting,
are,
uh,
a particular,
particular weaknesses for people with bipolar disorder.
So we're,
we're tailoring the intervention to try to um,
um,
help people with bipolar disorder have,
have more positive emotions so they're not engaging in this sort of dampening
coping response.
Again,
that Sherry and her team have found that people with bipolar tend to avoid all
positive events and it really impacts their quality of life.
So what we're trying to do is,
is give them skills for finding sort of the lower activation,
positive effect so they can have the experience of positive emotion and the
benefits with without the real dark side of the really high activation positive
that can then spin out of control.
And I think,
you know,
more generally that this is true for everyone.
Again,
it's,
it's the balance that you talked about.
Um,
and finding a place where if you're experiencing a significant life event are
not,
um,
you know,
drowning in the negative emotion.
Um,
that's,
you know,
adaptive and useful in many cases,
but you're not,
you're not overcome and overwhelmed by it.
And that the positive,
if you can practice some of these skills and bring more of the positive emotion
and as well,
maybe you can find that balance.
Yeah.
So it sounds like when you think about the implications for emotion and physical
health more generally,
it's this theme of just finding balance,
right?
And if there's a relative deficiency and positive emotion may be bumping up it
up a little,
but if there's an excess in positive emotionality kind of attenuating or curbing
it down a little to find that safe kind of sweet spot.
Right,
exactly.
And you know,
like everything in psychology,
it's probably really complicated on an individual level and your sweet spot is
probably different from my sweet spot is different from the next guy.
Sweet spot,
right?
So helping people find their individual optimal balance I think is going to be
one of the big challenges going forward.
So then when you think about going forward and sort of see the future of emotion
and how it relates to physical health,
we're,
where do you see the future headed?
Well,
one of the things I'm really excited about is um,
this uh,
movement board,
a mobile health and health information technology and being able to use various
types of sensors or things on your cell phone or ambulatory measures to really
get at both health in the field,
you know,
and health indicators in the field,
but also getting at emotion measurement in the field.
Um,
I am definitely a fan of self report emotion.
I think that people are very capable of reporting how they're feeling.
And I do think it's still the gold standard.
Um,
that said,
there are a lot of drawbacks to self report emotions,
particularly if you want to get at daily experience of emotion and moment to
moment experience of emotion.
And I think if there are ways for us to,
um,
a couple positive or self report with um,
some other sort of ambulatory,
um,
measure that at well that will be a huge leap forward.
So it is one of the things that we're experimenting with some of the things
where you can get at like heart rate variability in the field.
You can get at heart rates.
Certainly you can get at um,
galvanic skin response.
So,
um,
uh,
we're really excited about the possibility of being able to take all of these
um,
mobile or ambulatory measures that are non self report and,
and,
and bring them together in large samples and see is there a strong enough
correlation with self reported emotion to be able to use these going forward.
So that's,
you know,
today that's one of the things I'm really excited about.
Yeah,
no,
that's really exciting.
And I imagine you have a lot of students who will to you and ask you for advice,
you know,
that they're thinking about embarking in this field.
What should I do,
you know,
how should I spend my time?
Um,
what kind of advice do you give to students who are thinking about embarking in
emotion?
Um,
I think,
I mean certainly the thing that stands out to me when I'm talking to a student
is if they've got a real passion for the question.
Um,
so my advice would be find the question that you get really excited about.
I think,
you know,
there's often a pull toward doing what's being done in your graduate lab or
being done.
It's your university and that's all really good and it's a way to get exposure.
But,
um,
sometimes that overall question is interesting.
It may be,
may not be what's really exciting to you.
And I think,
uh,
you know,
if you're going to stay in it for the long term and there,
there will be bumps along the way and it's challenging to make a career in,
um,
psychology or certainly in psychology and health,
you need a question that's going to sustain you and it needs to be something
you're really passionate about and you can imagine studying forever.
Um,
so yeah,
find,
find the question you're really passionate about.
I like that advice of finding your passion.
It's so important.
Um,
and I think that's a great note to conclude on that,
you know,
it's all about passions science to keep it going for the longterm.
That's right.
So thank you so much for speaking today,
Judy.
Thanks.
It's been a lot of fun.
Thank you.
Great to see you
two.
Okay,
so this concludes our experts in emotion interview with Doctor Judith Moscowitz
from the University of California San Francisco.